Oh
fascinating new book by Diana Slattery
called xeno linguistics psychedelics in
the evolution of the language which
builds on McKenna's notions that the
world is made of language and you know
the words the world made of you can make
of it whatever you wish and like neo in
the matrix when he sees the code right
so what does this mean this notion that
reality is made of language is it mere
metaphor is it near poetry
well McKenna and Diana Slattery say that
actually the metaphor is literalized we
actually look at the big picture even
biology is made of language biology is
code DNA is code it's software that
writes its own hardware the words come
before the matter emerges just think
about that you know because it resonates
in all kinds of transitions away this
notion that that mind came before matter
that mine didn't emerge from matter but
rather than mine to proceeded matter in
its it's a wild idea but does seem to be
that everything everything can be
described in terms of words whether it's
music whether it's the atoms that
describe the laws of physics I mean it's
all describable it's it's all
information so wild idea we're thinking
about
you